[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
moi Deeb's teachings have become the
playground of scholastics of the
superstitious and the corrupt he taught
a balanced way of life a philosophy by
which a human can meet problems arising
from an ever-changing universe
he said mankind is still evolving in a
process which will never end he said
this evolution moves on change in
principles which are known only to
Eternity how can corrupted reasoning
play with such an essence Children of
Dune takes place nine years after dune
Messiah in this time the Empire is ruled
by Aliyah Atreides who maintains the
Regency until Paul's twins Leto and
Ghani macum of age Paul's twins are like
no other children that have ever lived
before in truth their millions of years
old a perfect combination of genes and a
mother's heavy consumption of spice led
these children to become preborn forced
into consciousness with all the memories
of their ancestors
although alia was pre born as the twins
were she does not share their experience
the twins connections to their past
lives seems to be more fluid alia
avoided the intricacies over her inner
world and therefore did not possess the
mental linkages that the twins had for
example they were able to speak fluently
in many ancient languages where alia
would only be able to catch a word or
two alia now has undergone the spice
trance and as the result the
unimaginable has happened the very thing
the Reverend mother Gaius helen mo
higham feared in book 1 that child is an
abomination
her mother deserves a punishment greater
than any in history death it cannot come
too quickly for that child or the one
who spawned her
when a child is pre born the weight of
the ancestral memories is crushing if
the child cannot form a sufficient ego a
more dominant ego within the other
memories would take possession of the
person the meninges recall this
abomination these abominations were
feared and considered very dangerous by
The Sisterhood anyone who was believed
to be abomination was immediately killed
this is why the Reverend Mother calls
for a Lea's death in doomed why did you
abandon alia the Nima asked I fled in
terror of what I created Jessica said
her voice low I gave up and my burden
now is that perhaps I gave up too soon
what do you mean I cannot explain yet
but maybe no I'll not give you false
hopes Baffler the abominable distraction
has a long history in human mythology it
was called many things but chiefly it
was called possession that's what it
seems to be you lose your way in the
malignancy and it takes possession of
you alia is possessed abomination her
mind infected with the evil presence of
her grandfather the Baron Harkonnen
whose ego memory now seeks revenge
against House Atreides he has poisoned
alia psyche and there is seemingly no
help for her the Baron is a constant
shadow in a Lea's mind watching through
her eyes the twins have recognized this
and only pity alia they worried though
that they even may one day succumb to
possession
in the decades since dune Messiah the
planet Arrakis has changed drastically
the ecological transformation has led to
the point where there are now clouds and
the skies of doom it even rained on
occasion instead of still suits many
Freeman out took pills which shift at
the body's temperature and reduced water
loss why should they when rain have been
recorded on this planet when clouds were
seen when eight Freeman had been
inundated and killed by a flash flood in
Ord until that event the word drowned
had not existed in the language of dune
but this was no longer dune
this was eraqus thoughts of still gar as
the planet has changed freman culture
has eroded many freemen have left the
sieges for the villages and cities still
gar has noticed this change and he has
changed as well over time he has come to
realize that Paul Muad'Dib was also
flesh and blood not a messiah he is now
much wiser than he was in the days
before Paul walked into the desert yet
still he longs for what he refers to as
cleaner values still gar longs for a
time when he could believe without
question when he didn't have to consider
the fact that the jihad was killing
millions because he knew that it was the
will of God and God had a plan now that
still gar knows the truth he has become
more like Paul more like God and he
cannot unsee the horror that Paul always
saw hence him longing for cleaner values
he longs for a simpler time when he was
more naive about what was really going
on
Children of Dune opens at a very
interesting time it is on this very day
that the lady Jessica returns to Arrakis
for the first time since the day she
left for Caledon 20 years ago Aliyah is
anxious about Jessica's return she knows
of Jessica's power as a been a Jesuit
Reverend Mother and she fears that her
mother will recognize the signs of
abomination Jessica's return also shakes
the balance of power
Arrakis jessica is the mother of moooo
Dean and would have huge sway over the
Fremen it has also been rumored that
lady Jessica has returned to the Biddy
Jesuit sisterhood alia is extremely
bitter towards the sisterhood and her
mother she blames them for the way that
she is the sisterhood had only been
seeking to breed a quiz at satiric the
male counterpart of a fully-developed
reverend mother and more a human of
superior sensitivity and awareness the
quiz acts had around who could be in
many places simultaneously and the lady
Jessica merely a pawn in that breeding
program had the bad taste to fall in
love with the breeding partner to who
she had been assigned responsive to her
beloved Dukes wishes she produced a son
and said of the daughter which the
sisterhood had commanded as the
firstborn leaving me to be born after
she became addicted to the spice and now
they don't want me now they fear me with
good reason
alia has come to realize that the
ecological transformation which now
grips the planet will ultimately result
in the death of all the worms spice
production would end the twins have
realized this as well and the creature
inside alia desperately desires this
when Jessica returns to Arrakis her
minion Jesuit powers immediately forced
her to become aware of many things she
notices that many of the million or so
that have gathered to witness the
arrival of the mother of god are
pilgrims these pilgrims have been
arriving more and more in order to
experience the planet of the messiah
Jessica also notices that both aerilon
and alia
are utilizing forbidden vintages or
techniques to prevent aging she refers
to this as an affront many Reverend
mothers could choose that course or try
it the manipulation of internal
chemistry was available to initiates of
The Sisterhood but if one did it sooner
or later all would try it there could be
no concealing such an accumulation of
ageless women they knew for certainty
that this course would lead them to
destruction short-lived humanity would
turn upon them no it was unthinkable
using this technique of any Jesuit could
potentially live for thousands of years
but the sisterhood understood that the
backlash from a universe which relied on
spice to extend life would be too great
and ultimately lead the sisterhood to
annihilation this is why Jessica is
disturbed by both Irulan and aleeah's
use of this technique but jessica
noticed something far more terrible in
alia the rumors were true
horrible horrible alia had fallen into
the forbidden way the evidence was there
for the initiate to read abomination
Jessica instantly recognizes the signs
of possession in her daughter and knows
from that moment on that her daughter is
her enemy she wonders then if the twins
too have succumbed to abomination
recently on Arrakis a mysterious blind
man known as the preacher has appeared
he speaks blasphemy against the church
and also against the government many
people believe him to be Paul Atreides
himself alia and the twins view this as
a possibility alia wishes to have the
preacher arrested for heresy
he raised both arms and roared in a
voice which surely had commanded warn
riders silence the entire throne in the
plaza went still at that battle crime
the preacher pointed a thin and toward
the dancers and the illusion that he
actually saw them was uncanny did you
not hear this man blasphemous and
idolaters all of you the religion of
Muad'Dib is not more demon he spurns it
as he spurns you sand will cover this
place sand will cover you saying this he
dropped his arms put a hand on his young
guy's shoulder and commanded take me
from this place far away on the planet
SaLuSa secundus whence Asiya Corino the
younger sister of Irulan plots treachery
her plot involves assassinating the
twins using laser Tigers large and
powerful cats who could be controlled
from a distance by a transmitter due to
servo stimulators implanted in their
brains as Cubs lazer Tigers were a
special breed brought to the planet
nearly eight thousand years ago they
were created through genetic
manipulation of original Tigers they
have huge things wide faces and enlarged
paws their coats were an even colored
tan perfect for blending against sand
when sisyas sun Feridun is not aware of
his mother's plan when cecile wishes to
steal the imperial seat from House
Atreides and make farad and Emperor once
Jessica is alone with the twins on
Arrakis she can see that gana ma is not
possessed Leto however she is not sure
something about him disturbs her when
she is alone with him he demonstrates
his power to her throughout their
conversation he manipulates her for
voice and eventually breaks her many
Jesuit conditioning abruptly she
realized that the quickened breath the
pounding heart were not Laden
not held at bay by herb any Jesuit
control eyes widening and shocked
awareness she felt her own flesh obeying
other commands slowly she recovered her
poise but the realization remained this
uncharred
had been playing her like a fine
instrument throughout their interview
now you know how profoundly you are
conditioned by your precious spinning
Jesuits he said the realization that
Leto had been manipulating her through
their conversation shatters Jessica's
reality she is still however unsure
about Leto though she observes his power
Leto commands Jessica to allow herself
to be abducted by aliens men Leto is
aware that prescience is what destroyed
his father he knows that within the spy
strands lies even greater risk for
himself Leto has seen three possible
futures in one he must kill Jessica in
order to prevent the loss of the spice
monopoly in the second he would marry
his sister Janina for the sake of House
Atreides
but the third future would permit him to
live millennia and require him to
undhiyo fayez father to remove Paul's
godhood Aliyah and Duncan's relationship
has become strained in Children of Dune
since her possession she has engaged in
an affair with Javeed the high priest of
the quizzer at Duncan Idaho's Mint at
abilities kick in whilst alia is
attempting to convince him to help her
kidnap Jessica he realizes that alia has
succumbed to possession he points out to
alia that the simpler option would be to
kill the lady Jessica and he notices the
signs of an alien presence when she
seems clearly pleased by the suggestion
though she stills the emotion quickly
don't gain agrees to kidnap Jessica but
insists that alia not know where he is
taking her he tells her that this way
she would be immune to the power of a
truth singer he leaves her thing and
tears fall from his metal eyes alia is
found
in secret the heretic preacher journeys
to the planet SaLuSa secundus and meets
Feridun nephew to Irulan and future
leader of house Kirino the preacher
promises Feridun that he will have
duncan idaho as his agent Feridun finds
the preacher strange and indecipherable
at the halfway mark of Children of Dune
aleeah's true intentions are revealed
when she attempts to assassinate the
lady Jessica in the open now look at her
Jessica pointed at Maliha she lasts
alone at night in contemplation of her
own evil spice production will fall to
nothing or at best a fraction of its
former level and when word of that gets
out will have a corner on the most
priceless product in the universe alia
shouted will have a corner on hell
Jessica raged and alia lapsed into the
most ancient shake hopes up the Atreides
private language with its difficult
glottal stops and clicks now you know
mother did you think a granddaughter of
Baron Harkonnen would not appreciate all
of the lifetimes you crushed into my
awareness before I was even born when I
arranged against what you've done to me
I had only asked myself what the Baron
would have done and he answered
understand me Atreides [ __ ] he answered
me Jessica hurt the venom and the
confirmation of her guests abomination
alia had been overwhelmed with in
possessed by that Kuwait of evil the
Baron Vladimir Harkonnen the Baron
himself spoke from her mouth now
uncaring of what was revealed he wanted
her to see his revenge wanted her to
know that he could not be cast out
jessica manages to escape from alia into
the desert with the help of the fate
Akina now that the mother of Paul
Atreides has renounced alia the Freeman
are now in open rebellion
during these events the twins have also
escaped into the desert in search of the
preacher it is in the desert that they
are attacked by the lazy Tigers who have
been brought on the planet by wimp
Cecilia Kirino with the help of Furman
traders the children defeat the Tigers
but not easily and it is at this point
that they began the next phase in their
plan they split Leto leaves going deeper
into the desert to seek out the preacher
Gani mom asked her own memory through a
form of self-hypnosis she implants false
memories of her brother's death truly
believing it thus making her immune to
the power of a truth singer guinea masti
old
for what she had to do Leto must be dead
in her mind she had to make herself
believe it there could be no jackaroo to
in her mind
no brother out there seeking a place
lost in Freeman mythology from this
point onward she could not think of Leto
as alive
she must condition herself to act out of
a total belief that her brother was dead
killed here by Laser Tigers not many
humans could fool a truth assayer but
she knew that she could do it might have
to do it the motile lives she and Leto
shared had taught them the way when
Jessica had first returned to Arrakis
captives were taken from a throng of
people awaiting her when subjected to
what gurney Halleck describes as the
deep drugs some of the captives spoke
the name Jack arute - and as they said
the word they died it is assumed that
they were conditioned for this reaction
long before the days of House Atreides
on Arrakis before Liat coins before the
rule of Shaddam the forth there were
certain tribes that roam the desert
known as water hunters the freeman
called them in to Wally water insects
they would still the watcher of Freeman
they caught in the desert even the water
of the body thus each they lived in was
called Jack arute - and it was in Jack
arute - that
other Freeman tribe is band together to
destroy the Diwali the place was
considered taboo after that and from
that day forth no Freeman had gone to
Jack arute to its very location was lost
the remaining Diwali according to legend
were cast out from Freeman's society
foremost Freeman Jack arute ooh was
considered a myth but Leto has begun to
have prescient dreams of Jack arute -
and believes he can find the preacher
there from the desert Jessica sends a
letter to still guard telling him that
Aliyah is indeed possessed whilst
waiting for a response
Duncan Idaho arrives having been sent by
still guard
Jessica allows Duncan to abduct her she
tells him that Aliyah is no longer a
tradies and that he is bound to the
Atreides Duncan is saddened by this but
he agrees and admits that he is taking
her to SaLuSa secundus on behalf of the
preacher who for some reason has asked
that she train Feridun in the Binnie
jesuit way jessica suspects that duncan
may know the true identity of the
preacher so she asks if the preacher is
indeed Paul but Duncan does not know
truly on SaLuSa Feridun has learned of
his mother winds to see his plan to kill
the Atreides twins he is however unsure
how to feel about it
by the time Duncan and Jessica arrive of
SaLuSa secundus
the word of late to the second death has
spread and also word that Aliyah has
agreed to submit herself to the Freeman
trial of possession which would
determine the truth of the matter and in
in Ali's death if the accusation proved
valid alia agrees to this in an effort
to calm the civil war which is broken
out between the imperial Freeman and the
desert Freeman many including Feridun do
not understand the purpose of this trial
of the session
Jessica tells Feridun that she has come
to his planet at the suggestion of The
Sisterhood to oversee his education she
tells him that to make this work she
would need to be given free rein on
SaLuSa Duncan's mint at powers kicking
him and he finds himself amused by the
situation
he explains suggesting that they had
been tricked he has realized that
Feridun is expected to do away with both
he and Jessica that way an open clash
could occur between the Imperial House
Atreides and House Kirino the mini
Jesuit sisterhood could then step in an
arbitrary marriage between Feridun and
Camilla and at last have control over a
closets had rack
Jessica now understands that the
sisterhood lied to her because they
wanted her out of the way since she had
failed them before Jessica convinces
Feridun to accept her offer she tells
him that she will train him as she did
her son Paul many years ago later when
duncan speaks to jessica he renounces
House Atreides and speaks of how there
are now entire groups of Freeman who
curse their name at the preachers
bidding
he joined one of the group's Bazaar
Saudis Jessica is not sure of dumpkins
intentions and they both know that
Feridun is having their conversation
recorded she attempts to get more
information out of Duncan but Duncan
resists and wonders if he had finally
breached the walls of her many Jesuit
training I had a hoe backed away from
her until he felt the door behind him he
bowed
once more I called you my lady and then
never again
my advice to Feridun will be to send you
back to Wallach quietly and quickly at
the earliest practical moment you are
too dangerous a toy to keep around
although I don't believe he thinks of
you as a toy you are working for The
Sisterhood not for the Atreides I wonder
now if you ever worked for the Atreides
you which is moved to deeply and art Lee
for mere mortals to ever trust Angola
considers himself a mere mortal
she jibed compared to you he said leave
she ordered such is my intention he
slipped out the door passing the curious
stare of the servant who table viously
been listening it's done he thought and
they can read it only one way outward
Lee it would seem that duncan has
abandoned house Atreides and gone over
fully to house Kirino
but Duncan's inner monologue would
suggest otherwise though there is a
warrant for the arrest of the preacher
on Arrakis he appears in the square on
quiz that's had a wreck day to give a
sermon on the death of Leto the 2nd alia
has disguised herself as a commoner and
gone out into the crowd to hear she has
long suspected that the preacher is in
fact Paul and she fears him but no she
cannot harm him
with a terrifying directness the
preacher reached out grabbed a Leah's
arm it was done without any groping or
hesitation she tried to pull away but he
held her in a painful grip speaking
directly into her face as those around
them edged back in confusion what did
Paul Atreides tell you woman he demanded
how does he know I'm a woman she asked
herself she wanted to sink into her
inner lives asked their protection but
the world within remained frightenedly
silent mesmerised by this figure from
their past he told you that completion
equals death the preacher shouted
absolute prediction is completion is
death she tried to pry his fingers away
she wanted to grab her knife and slash
him away from her but she dared not she
had never felt this daunted in all her
life
the preacher lifted his chin to speak
over her to the crowd shouted I give you
more Deeb's words he said I'm going to
rub your faces in things you try to
avoid I don't find it strange that all
you want to believe is only that which
comforts you how else do humans invent
the traps which betray us into
mediocrity how else do we define
cowardice that's what MOA Deeb told you
abruptly he released aleus arm thrust
her into the crowd she would have fallen
but for the press of people supporting
her to exist is to stand out away from
the background the preacher said you
aren't thinking or really existing
unless you're willing to risk even your
own sanity in judgment of your existence
stepping down the preacher once more
took a Leah's arm no faltering or
hesitation he was gentler this time
though leaning close he pitched his
voice for her ears alone stop trying to
pull me once more into the background
sister then hand on his young guide
shoulder he stepped into the throne way
was made for the strange pair hands
reached out to touch the preacher
but people reached with an awesome
tenderness fearful of what they might
find beneath that dusty fremen robe
Illya stood alone in her shock as the
throng moved out behind the preacher
certainty filled her it was Paul no
doubt remained it was her brother
abandoned certainty that's life's
deepest command that's what life's all
about we probe into the unknown into the
uncertain why can't you hear more deep
if certainty is knowing absolutely an
absolute future then that's only death
disguised such a future becomes now Leto
has driven a worm deep into the desert
and has finally found the place he
believes to be Jack arute ooh but he is
concerned when he can find no trace of
water he heads to the siege and is
captured by a man who forces him
unconscious when Leto wakes he sees
Mamre father of Javeed the lover and
servant of Aliyah Mamre tells him that
he must complete schooling in this place
and if he didn't he would die memory
also tells Leto that he soon will come
face to face with the man who captured
him when Leto wakes again he sees the
face of none other than gurney Halleck
who was sent to capture him on Jessica's
orders their plan is to force Leto to
undergo the spice trance as Paul did and
begin unlocking his vision he saw the
aleutian the entire illusion process
rotated half a turn and now he knew a
center from which he could watch without
purpose the flight of his visions of his
inner lies elation flooded him it made
him want to laugh but he denied himself
this luxury knowing it would bar the
doors of memory
memories he thought I have seen your
illusion
you no longer invent the next moment for
me you merely show me how to create new
moments I'll not lock myself on the old
tracks repeatedly he was forced into
spiced rents and each time he came out
memory and gurney were aren't sure
whether or not to slay him Leto sees
much in his visions and at times nearly
loses sight of himself within the
boundaries of time he tells mamrie and
gurney that the problem with his
father's rule of the Empire was that it
sought to bring peace but however peace
was only defined by a specific way of
life which did not leave people
contented
he tells Kearney that he will indeed one
day work with the sisterhood but they
will not like it
the visions caused later to grow very
weak and he curses his grandmother for
utilizing such a drawn-out Gulman Jabbar
meanwhile aerilon and alia have been
trying to convince Egon EEMA to accept
Feridun proposal Dyneema is furious and
wants to kill Feridun as revenge for
Latos death even though he has blamed
his mother for the attack Irulan even at
one point attempts to use voice on
ghanima
of this backfires horribly why'd you and
alia grow so suddenly quiet aerilon
asked reverting to her previous question
but casting it now in a delicate mode of
voice ghanima threw back her head in
laughter Irulan you try voice on me what
Irulan was taken aback you teach her
grandmother to suck eggs minima's said
i'd what the fact that I remember the
expression and you've never heard it
before should give you pause Dyneema
said it was an old expression of scored
when you Benny Jesuit were young ghanima
is done being treated like a child and
angrily insists that Irulan and alia
leave her presence but alia is intrigued
by the Nima's anger and makes a deal
with her she will marry Feridun to get
the lady Jessica back but she would kill
Feridun
first chance she got though Irulan is
against this Dyneema is insistent on
SaLuSa secundus
jessica has begun the slow process of
training Feridun in the mini jesuit ways
Feridun learns the teachings faster than
Jessica expected but he is still in the
very early stages during the storm Leto
escapes Kearney into the desert - he
takes a still suit and a still tent with
him Leto heads directly into the storm
and hides within the tent to wait it out
however when he awakes he founds the
hill pumps on his still suit have been
cut and he has lost half of his water he
finds a worm and rides it deeper into
the desert until he comes across a band
the freeman renegades
he soon discerns that they are from
shulock stories of shulock were often
shared amongst freeman everyone
considered it to be a myth a place for
interesting things to happen only for
the sake of a story Leto has now fully
realized what has happened the original
jackaroo - had indeed been renamed Fonda
and had become a place for smugglers but
the cast out of Jack arute - had gone to
shoe luck
he knows that this is where he will find
the preacher he reveals to Morris that
he is the son of Paul Atreides and tells
him that if they kill him his people
will sink into the sand but if they let
him live he will lead them to greatness
and uneasy alliances form between Leto
and mirus you speak of leading us Mira
said Fremen are led by men who have been
bloodied what can you lead us in Crowley
Zack later said keeping his attention on
the Crouch to figure mirrors glared at
him brows contracted over his indigo
eyes Krell ASEC that wasn't merely a war
a revolution that was the Typhoon's
struggle it was a word from the
furthermost Freeman legends the battle
at the end of the universe
Krell ASEC in the dune universe
Crowley Zack is the long foretold mythic
battle at the end of the universe
a legend but here Leto implies that it
is actually real back at fom dak Mamre
reveals to gurney that he has in fact
been following the orders of alia and
not Jessica as he believed it was Aliyah
who wished to subject Leto to the spice
trance gurney ends up killing the man
and escapes to find still gar knowing
that alia will want him dead
in Schulich the golden path begins Leto
goes to the cannot where the worms and
the sand trout are kept the cast out of
Sherlock have been selling the worms
offworld though they do not live long
Leto allows one of the sand kraut to
cover his end on Arrakis fremen children
often played a game if a sand trout was
placed in a hand it would since the
water in the capillaries and covered the
entire hand eventually the sad shout
glove would fall off having been
repelled by something in the Bloods
water sand crowd can joined together
locking body to body in order to become
a single sac-like organism enclosing a
body of water he allows the central to
cover his whole body creating a sand
route membrane which behaves like a
living permanent still suit the sand
route membrane adjusted too late his
body and begin integrating changing him
into something not quite human something
beyond human the sand route had never
before encountered a body containing so
much spice later adjusted his internal
enzymes and blended himself with the
sand trout feeding it and feeding on it
his vision provided all the knowledge he
needed to do so and he followed it
perfectly the sand trout was no longer
sand route but something tougher and
stronger and he knew that it would only
grow stronger giving him godlike
strength and speed he got to his feet
turned to run back toward the hut as he
moved he found his feet moving too fast
for him to balance he plunged into the
sand rolled and leapt to his feet the
leap took him two metres off the sand
and when he fell back trying to walk he
again moved too fast stop he commanded
himself he fell into the piranhas Bindu
forced relaxation gathering his senses
into the pool of consciousness this
focused the inward ripples of the
constant now through which he
experienced time and he allowed the
vision elation to warm
the membrane worked precisely as the
vision had predicted my skin is not my
own the sand trout membrane would also
provide Leto with unlimited spice and he
could swim through the sands with
lightning speed face to face Leto
confronts a worm out in the deep desert
he finds that it will not harm him worms
will not attack sand trout the deep sand
vector of its own kind he decides that
he will use his powers to destroy the
center's key to the ecological
transformation of Arrakis this would set
the transformation back decades and
would allow Leto to rearrange the plan
for Arrakis he knew that only the
necessities of his vision mattered now
only the golden path could come from
this ordeal here was the great leap onto
the golden path he had put on the living
self-repairing still suit of a sand
trout membrane a thing of unmeasurable
value on Arrakis until you understood
the price I am no longer human the
legends about this night will grow and
magnify it beyond anything recognizable
by the participants but it will become
truth that legend in the deep desert
Leto places himself in the path of
Paul's worm and the creature stops
Paul's guide is tarik son of mirrors
later reveals himself and insists that
he and his father spend the evening
together using a pseudo shield Tariq
attempts to kill Paul and Leto by
utilizing the maddening effect that the
Holtzman effect has on the great worms
nothing could stop a worm in the
presence of a shield not water or the
presence of Sandro
Tariq had been commanded by Jack arute
to to do away with both Atreides it is
at this point that the separate visions
of Paul and Leto come into conflict the
preacher following the sound of Latos
voice clambered up the dune slope and
stood two paces away it was done with a
swift sureness which told Leto this
would be no easy
contest here the vision started when
Paul walked into the desert many years
ago he had truly wanted to die when the
baby Leto had shared sight with him
Paul had had a vision he was resigned to
be a tool of revenge for Jack arute to
Jack arute who had been waiting for him
that night as he knew they would be they
wanted his visions but he gave them none
even when they forced him into trance
using the spiced essence he had baited
alia confused and tempted her into
making incorrect decisions
jackaroo too used Paul as bait to trap
Aliyah and now she knows that the
preacher is indeed Paul Paul is prepared
to die he ran from Latos vision and Leto
felt the tension grow between himself
and his father it was a shadow play all
around them a projection of unconscious
forms and Leto felt the memories of his
father a form of backwards prophecy
which sordid visions from the familiar
reality of this moment Paul insists to
Leto that he cannot control the future
but Leto knew that one of them would
have to act make a decision choosing a
vision Leto understood however that Paul
was correct attempting to take ultimate
control of the universe could only lead
to the ultimate defeat of you to manage
such a vision required a balance of a
single thin thread to play God on a
tight wire with cosmic solitude on both
sides Leto had committed himself down a
path in which there was now no turning
back from and he had accepted the
consequences of that choice Paul however
had made no final commitment though Paul
begs him not to Leto stayed in line with
his own vision he jumps meters into the
air catching tarik and breaking his neck
instantly then he dug the pseudo shield
out of the ground and hurled it far off
in the distance
Paul had been defeated here Leto looked
upon his father and saw a blind angry
man full of despair
do you really know the universe you have
created here Leto heard the particular
emphasis the vision which both of them
knew had been sent into terrible motion
here had required an act of creation at
a certain point in time for that moment
the entire sentient universe shared a
linear view of time which possessed
characteristics of orderly progression
they entered this time as they might
step onto a moving vehicle and they
could only leave it the same way Leto
had locked humanity into his vision they
could not leave it paul asked Leto if he
is truly prepared to commit to his fate
if he is truly willing to change and
live for thousands of years he wonders
if Leto is ready to accept what he will
be to the universe do you wish to live
those thousands of years changing as you
know you will change linked Hill
recognized that his father was not
speaking about physical changes both of
them knew the physical changes later
would adapt and adapt the skin which was
not his own would adapt and adapt the
evolutionary thrust of each part would
melt into the other and a single
transformation would emerge when
metamorphosis came if it came a thinking
creature of awesome dimensions would
emerge upon the universe and that
universe would worship Him no Paul was
referring to the inner changes the
thoughts and decisions which would
inflict themselves upon the worshippers
it is here that Leto first speaks of his
metamorphosis the Millennia's long
change that will shape his body into an
inhuman form he would be worshipped and
his grip upon the universe will be
stronger than Paul's ever was or could
have ever dreamed to be
thousands of peaceful years later said
that's what I'll give them donut see
sack nation of course and those forms of
violence which I permit it'll be a
lesson which humankind will never forget
I Spit on your lesson Paul said you
think I have not seen a thing similar to
what you choose you saw it
later agreed is your vision any better
than mine not one whit better worse
perhaps later said then what can I do
but resist you Paul demanded Paul
concedes to Leto acknowledging that this
is his universe now he knew that he
would have no comfort this night or any
other he knew that muadh e must be
destroyed
Paul Atreides the hero must die only the
preacher could survive he would do Latos
bidding Illya has now begun to show
signs of possession in her physical form
her flesh is beginning to change from
the prolonged abomination she has grown
more and more deranged Duncan Idaho now
on Arrakis is at siege to boar and has
been trying to convince still gar that
alia is possessed but still gar is
unsure of Duncan's motives Javeed
aleeah's lover is also apt to bore and
when Duncan seized him he is overcome
with rage he murders two vide still
guard is extremely angry that Duncan had
defiled the siege breaking its
neutrality Duncan provokes still gar
insulting him in ways in which of
Freeman cannot ignore you've defiled my
honor
still bar cried this is neutral shut up
Duncan glared at the shocked naive you
wear a collar still guard it was one of
the three most deadly insults which
could be directed at a freeman steel
gars face went pale
you're a servant Idaho said you sold
Freeman for their water this was the
second most deadly insult the one which
had destroyed the original Jack arute to
still guard round his teeth put a hand
on his Chris knife
the aide stepped back away from the body
in the doorway turning his back on the
naive Idaho stepped into the door
taking the narrow opening beside Javed's
body and speaking without turning
delivered the third insult you have no
immortality still Garr none of your
descendants carry your blood where do
you go now mint at still gar called as
Idaho continued leaving the room still
gars voice was as cold as wind from the
poles to find Jack arute to Idaho said
still not turning still guard drew his
knife perhaps I can help you
Idaho was at the outer lip of the
passage now without stopping he said if
you'd help me with your knife water
thief please do it in my back that's the
fitting way for one who wears the collar
of a demon with two leaping strides
still gar crossed the room stepping on
Javed's body and caught Idaho in the
outer passage one gnarled hand jerked
Idaho around and to a stop
still gar confronted Idaho and bared
teeth and a draw knife such was his rage
that still guarded not even see the
curious smile on Idaho's face draw your
knife Mentats come still gar roared
Idaho laughed he cuffs still gar sharply
left hand right in to stinging slaps to
the head with an incoherent screech
still guard drove his knife into Idaho's
abdomen striking upward through the
diaphragm into the heart idaho sagged
onto the blade grinned up at still gar
whose rage dissolved into sudden I see
shocked to deaths for the Atreides idaho
haas ii for no better reason in the
first he lurched sideways collapsed to
the stone floor on his face
blood spread out from his wound
Duncan calls still gar a slave of a
demon the abomination that lives within
alia says that he has killed Freeman for
their water the greatest Freeman crime
and implies that still gar is sterile
and has no children of his own blood it
is here that still gar kills Duncan only
realizing afterwards that this was
Duncan's intent now still gar has no
option but to flee from Illya publicly
alia would have to retaliate against
still gar for killing her consort even
though she had already planned to do
away with Duncan when she realized she
couldn't fully trust him realizing all
this still guard takes kanima Irulan and
his wives along with anyone else in the
siege who wishes to go with him into the
desert he knows that he is ganene is
only hope for survival a Lea's grief an
inner turmoil continues to grow she
feels as though she is split in half two
people one consumed by pain and the
other perplexed by her tears in the
desert there are now rumors of a desert
demon cannot SAR being destroyed and the
Fremen say this demon moves through the
dunes at this point still gars company
along with Janie ma have been travelling
for months Janina notices how the
shattered cannot have been affecting the
land and the behavior of the freeman the
desert demon is of course Leto who is
now worshiped by the cast out at
Schulich when he had brought gurney
Halleck and the preacher there he had
demonstrated his power to the men of the
cast out with his bare hands
Leto had breached the Schulich not
hurling large stones more than 50 meters
when the cast out have tried to
intervene Leto had to capitate at the
first to reach him using no more than a
blurred sweep of his arm he hurled
others back into their companions and
had laughed at their weapons in a
demon's voice he roared at them fire
will not touch me your knives will not
harm me I wear the skin of Shai allude
in Arrakeen Feridun and the lady Jessica
have arrived on Arrakis alia has
captured still gar and his party
including Dyneema by putting a tracker
on a messenger Leto has brought the
preacher to the city and he gives a
sermon as Feridun Jessica Aliyah and
still gar watch from Elias chambers when
the preacher calls Aliyah blasphemy her
priests descend upon him killing the
preacher then a voice screeched from the
mob more deep they've killed who Adeeb
gods below alia quavered gods below a
little late for that don't you think
Jessica asked alia world noting the
sudden startled reaction of Feridun as
he saw the rage on her face that was
Paul they killed alia screamed that was
your son when they confirm it do you
know what will happen
Jessica is struck by this but she cannot
deny aleeah's words Paul Atreides now
lies dead an amount of bloody rags
amongst the temple steps at that moment
the thick plasteel construction that was
the door to Elias chambers flew off the
hinges and came hurling into the room
the guards leaped out of the way to
avoid it in walked Leto holding a Nima
by the arm as she attempted to escape
him but he shook her arm and her whole
body shook with in uttering a trigger
word Leto breaks Guinea's memory
conditioning here is Arya the Atreides
lioness we come to set you onto such
enemy the Golden Path kanima absorbing
the trigger words such an employee
felt the locked away consciousness flow
into her mind it flowed with a linear
nadi the inner awareness of her mother
hovering there behind it a guardian at a
gate and anima knew in that instant that
she had conquered the clamorous past she
possessed a gate through which she could
peer when she needed into that past
the months of self-hypnotic suppression
had built for her a safe place from
which to manage her own flesh Geneva's
conditioning is broken and through this
Geneva has overcome the possibility of
abomination she can now freely look
through the memories of her past lives
without fear of possession Aliyah
commands her guards to seize Leto but
seeing his awesome power they refused to
enter the room Leto walks across the
room towards Aliyah and though she tries
to fight him he deals with her easily it
is here that the inner lives of a Lea's
mind come to the surface and her
possession is there for all to see
aleeah's eyes darted wildly from side to
side I have conquered those inner lives
later said look at Ghani she too can
Dyneema interrupted Aliyah
I can show you know the word was
wrenched from alia her chest heaved and
the voice has begin to pour from her
mouth they were disconnected cursing
bleeding you see why didn't you listen
and again what are you doing what's
happening and another voice stop make
them stop Jessica covered her eyes felt
farad ins hands steady her still alia
raved I'll kill you hideous curses
erupted from her I'll drink your blood
the sound of many languages begin to
pour from her all jumbled and confused
the huddled guards in the outer passage
made the sign of the worm then held
clinched fists beside their ears she was
possessed shaking his head at the sight
of alia Leto walks to one of the windows
and breaks the supposedly unbreakable
crystal reinforced glass from its frame
alia rolled to her knees lurched to her
feet don't you know who I am she
demanded it was her old voice the sweet
and lilting voice of the youthful alia
who was no more why are you all looking
at me that way
she turned pleading eyes to Jessica
mother make them stop Jessica could only
shake her head from side to side
consumed by ultimate horror all of the
Bene Jesuit warnings were true she
looked at Leto and Gani standing side by
side near alia it is then that the Baron
himself speaks from Ali's mouth both
Leto and ghanima recognized his voice
from their own inner lives Dyneema began
to hear the same voice echo in her mind
but the inner gate sealed and in the
Barons place she sensed her mother
Shawnee standing there Leto gives alia a
choice the trial of possession or the
window who are you to give me a choice
alia demanded and it was still the voice
of the old barren demon the nema
screamed let her make her own choice
mother
alia pleaded in her little-girl tones
mother what are they doing what do they
want me to do help me
help yourself Leto ordered for just an
instant he saw the shattered presence of
his aunt in her eyes a glaring
hopelessness which peered out at him and
was gone but her body moved a stick let
rusting walk she wavered stumbled veered
from her path but returned to it nearer
and nearer the open window now the voice
of the old bear enraged from her lips
stop it stop it I say I command you stop
it
feel this alia clutched her head
stumbled closer to the window she had
the sill against her thighs then but the
voice still raged don't do this stop it
I'll help you I have a plan
listen to me stop it I say wait but alia
pulled her hands away from her head
clutched the broken casement in one
jerking motion she pulled herself over
the sill and was gone
not even a screech came from her as she
fell
in one instant of awareness alia was as
she once was and in that moment alia
overcame her possession killing the
bearing for the second time there is a
thump and the crowd below can be heard
screaming Jessica is overcome with grief
for the daughter she abandoned for the
daughter she lost long ago though
humanity will not know it Leto has made
a great sacrifice for them the skin
which is not his own can never be shed
he is no longer human and in 4000 years
the complete metamorphosis of the sand
crowd symbiote will destroy him the pain
of his life is great because the memory
of being human is richer in Leto than
any other person think of all those
lives cousin no you cannot imagine what
that is because you have no experience
of it but I know I can imagine his pain
he gives more than anyone ever gave
before our father walked into the desert
trying to escape it alia became
abomination in fear of it our
grandmother has only the blurred infancy
of this condition yet must use every
Binnie Jesuit while to live with it
which is what Reverend Mother training
amounts to anyway but Leto
he is all alone never to be duplicated
Leto is taking over the Bene Jesuit
Sisterhood's breeding program since he
is no longer human he cannot continue
the Atreides bloodline instead he will
continue it through ghanima and Feridun
he will himself marry ghanima
but no one will know that Feridun is the
true father of her children all Leto
does now is for the golden path he will
prepare humanity for krolow Zach saving
them though they will call him tyrant
he'll lead humans through the cult of
death into the free air of exuberant
life he speaks of death because that's
necessary still
it's a tension by which the living know
they're alive when his Empire Falls oh
yes it'll fall you think Crowley's ik is
now but Crowley's ik is yet to come
and when it comes fume ins will have
renewed their memory of what it's like
to be alive most of the great worms
would be gone in a hundred years the
guild whose navigators require such high
quantities of spice would nearly perish
in these famine times but they will
persist
once Leto returns into the sands of
Arrakis so will the worms and mankind
will arise from the ashes of Crowley Zek
Leto renames Feridun hoc alle da which
means the breaking of the habit he
commands him to hand over his sardick
our soldiers Leto intends to mingle them
with the Fremen
in the final chapter of Children of Dune
Leto reveals to hawk Aladar that he is
in fact possessed abomination by the
Benin jasmine ition Leto had forced back
most of his malevolent ego memories but
he had allowed one to take root the
eagle memory of a man named harem a man
who had bred humans who were short-lived
and prone to superstition easily led by
a god king Leto believes they were a
powerful people whose survival as a
species became habitual Leto mentions
that the reason the bene Jesuit breeding
program failed was because they
attempted to control evolution while
overlooking their own changes over the
course of that evolution he has no such
illusions I refused Feridun said you
refused to father and a tradies dynasty
what dynasty
you'll occupy the throne for thousands
of years and mold your descendants in my
image it will be the most intensive the
most inclusive training program in all
of history will be an ecosystem in
miniature you see whatever system
animals choose to survive by must be
based on the pattern of interlocking
communities interdependence working
together in the common design which is
the system and this system will produce
the most knowledgeable rulers ever seen
you put fancy words on a most
distasteful who will survive Carla Zack
like to ask I promise you
Crowley Zack will come you're a madmen
you will shatter the Empire of course I
will and I am NOT a man
but I'll create a new consciousness in
all men I tell you that below the desert
of doom there is a secret place with the
greatest treasure of all time I do not
lie when the last worm dies and the last
melange is harvested upon our sands
these deep treasures will spring up
throughout our universe as the power of
the spice monopoly fades and the hidden
stockpiles make their mark new powers
will appear throughout our realm it is
time humans learned once more to live in
their instincts Leto will bring peace
and stagnation to humanity for thousands
of years and then Krell ASEC new strange
powers will arise and humans yet again
will feel the tension of death Feridun
insists that he will resist Leto but
Leto tells him that he expects him to
and that this is in fact the reason he
was chosen Leto stands alone in the
universe he walks in solitude carrying
the weight of all mankind one of us had
to accept the agony kanima said and he
was always the stronger Children of Dune
is the completion of the first trilogy
in the doom series it is the beginning
of Latos long-term plan for history Leto
has made this sacrifice knowing that
humanity will curse his name for it they
could not possibly understand how one
whose vision stretches to the end of
time
seize the universe Children of Dune is
regarded as one of the greatest science
fiction books of all time intense action
and a gripping plot this novel unlike
doom Messiah is a sweeping epic much
like the original doom novel there are
multiple parallels between Paul and Leto
Children of Dune also shows the downfall
of alia who succumbs to possession by
the Baron Harkonnen alia had no choice
in her life this makes her end all the
more tragic the next book in the series
god emperor of dune takes place 3,500
years later it is in my opinion the most
profound novel in the series in it Leto
has morphed into the worm god emperor
and rules the Imperium with an iron fist
continuing to shape his golden path
[Music]
[Music]